Sam Alman, the CEO of OpenAI, has built
a doomsday bunker. It's buried and
hidden in the Navajo Desert. It's
stuffed with antibiotics, a hydroponic
food system, and weapons. This is the
same man racing to build artificial
general intelligence. Well, now it's
telling the world it's perfectly safe.
So, why prepare for catastrophe? To find
out, I went through practically every
interview, essay, podcast, panel, and
speech he's ever given. Very few people
know that in 2017, before he was in the
spotlight and years before Chat GBT,
Altman published blog posts with a
chilling theory that directly
contradicts what he says today. He wrote
that the AI species he's creating will
in fact lead to the end of the world as
we know it.
And his utopian vision is that we will
be effectively assimilated into an AI
powered hive mind. And his old posts get
even crazier. If there are two versions
of Altman, one who reassures the public
and one who prepares for the worst,
which one should we believe? And what I
found while digging wasn't just a single
contradiction. It was a pattern. One
that becomes more troubling the deeper
you look. May 16th, 2023, Sam Alman sits
in front of Congress calmly insisting
that AI is under control, that it's
being built safely. It's a tool, not a
creature. But I now think we are are
very much building a tool and not a
creature. In the last 2 years, he
repeats these lines over and over in
interviews, policy papers, even in front
of regulators. Meanwhile, OpenAI's
latest marketing materials claim that AI
won't cause real unemployment, which
conveniently aligns with what the Trump
administration wants to hear. But here's
the problem. If you look in OpenAI's
original charter, its core mission was
to build artificial general intelligence
that could replace basically all human
labor. That's a direct contradiction.
And Sam Alman helped write it. You see,
the deeper you look, the more these
contradictions show. Publicly, Alman
projects call. Privately, he's long
claimed that super intelligent AI is the
greatest threat to humanity's existence.
Yet politicians are lapping up his words
as though they're gospel, ignoring the
cunning behind his actions. Paul Graham
once said, "You could parachute Sam
Alman into an island full of cannibals
and come back in 5 years and he'd be the
king." And if you look at Sam's
statements some years ago, he sort of
happily said in one interview, um, this
stuff will probably kill us all. Now
he's saying you don't need to worry too
much about it. And I suspect that's
that's driven by seeking after money.
Does that sound like a man who believes
the public deserves the whole truth
about the technology reshaping their
lives? Or someone who knows how to tell
the exact story the world wants to hear?
I'm not sure, but if you look closely
enough, you'll see the cracks. Openai's
co-founder, Ilia Sudskerber, once said
behind closed doors, "We're definitely
going to build a bunker before we
release AGI." Any student of history
will tell you when someone writes down
their warnings, take them seriously.
People said Putin wouldn't invade
Ukraine. People said the horrors of
Hitler or Stalin were unpredictable. But
that's not true. The blueprint was
always there in the speeches, the
manifestos, the early essays. Minecom
outlined the Holocaust in plain
language. People just didn't believe it
until it was too late. That's why
looking at Altman's early writings
matters. In 2017, long before the world
had heard of chatbt, he published a blog
post titled the merge. And inside it are
lines like these. Unless we destroy
ourselves first, superhuman AI is going
to happen. Genetic enhancement is going
to happen and brain machine interfaces
are going to happen. It is a failure of
human imagination and human arrogance to
assume that we will never build things
smarter than ourselves. and development
of superhuman machine intelligence is
probably the greatest threat to the
continued existence of humanity.
Altman's thoughts may seem intense and
even exaggerated, but the thing is he's
not alone. The top three most decided AI
scientists agree with him, at least on
the greatest threats to humanity part.
So do the heads of every major AI lab.
And yet what Sam Alman says now in front
of Congress, regulators, and the press
is very different. It's measured,
reassuring, marketable. Now, you might
think this is just hyperbole from a tech
CEO trying to hype up his product. But
that doesn't explain it, not fully.
Because here's what we know for certain.
Alman was sounding the alarm on AI years
before OpenAI had a product to sell. And
now that OpenAI is valued at 300
billion, his message has clearly
shifted. But why? Maybe Altman saw the
stakes as far bigger than most people
realized. Maybe he believed that the
rise of superhuman AI can't be stopped
and that it was already underway. And if
that's true, then there's only one
logical conclusion. If you can't stop
it, you have to steer it or at the very
least survive it. Of course, we can't
know for sure what Alman was thinking.
But as I dug deeper into his writing,
one quote stopped me cold. Our phones
control us and tell us what to do when.
Social media feeds determine how we
feel. Search engines decide what we
think. Alman called this transformation
the merge. It's his belief that humanity
is facing a binary choice. Either we
fuse with our machines or we face
extinction. And here's the worst part.
Altman's timeline for this happening
isn't some distant future scenario. It's
a deadline that's rapidly approaching.
But just how soon are we talking about?
Sam Alman now says we will see AI
surpass humans in almost every way in as
little as 1 to 5 years. And again, I
cannot stress this enough, but the top
three most cited AI scientists, plus
every single major head of an AI lab
agrees with him on this, too. This
timeline is no longer a fringe belief.
It's the quiet consensus among top AI
researchers. And the craziest thing is
that just a few years ago, if you asked
these same scientists about AI, they'd
call it a tool, something we'd build,
tweak, and ultimately control. But that
belief is now dead. Because here's the
truth. We don't build these systems
anymore. It's more like we grow them.
What I mean is the systems we're
creating now, like chatbt, aren't coded
line by line. They're trained. And
they've started doing things even their
creators can't fully explain. So even
Altman is questioning this. Is this a
tool we have built or a creature we have
built? Jeffrey Hinton, the godfather of
AI, put it like this. We designed the
learning algorithm. That's a bit like
designing the principle of evolution.
But when this learning algorithm then
interacts with data, it produces
complicated neural networks that are
good at doing things, but we don't
really understand exactly how they do
those things. What we've produced in
these big chat bots is it's like a new
species that's very like us and very
unlike a normal computer program. I
think it is a mistake to assume that
they are humanlike in their thinking or
capabilities or limitations. I always
try to like think of it as an alien
intelligence uh and not try to project
my anthroorphic biases onto it. Let that
settle for a second. The most
influential person building these
systems thinks of AI as an alien
intelligence. And top researchers are
bitterly arguing whether they may
already be smarter than us. Jeffrey
Hinton puts it even more starkly. It's
as if aliens had landed, but we didn't
really take it in because they speak
good English. Or as the CEO of Microsoft
AI, Mustafa Sullyman said, "We are in
the process of seeing a new species grow
up around us." Remember, these are some
of the most accomplished people in their
fields. This isn't simple
fear-mongering. Even policymakers are
beginning to acknowledge this reality.
David Saxs deleted these tweets after
Trump appointed him as the
administration's new AIs are. AI is a
wonderful tool for the betterment of
humanity. A GI is a potential successor
species, a successor, not an assistant,
not a tool, a replacement. But let's
zoom out for a moment. Not to speculate,
but to face what might already be in
motion. If AI is becoming a new species,
smarter, faster, with its own goals,
then these warnings aren't paranoia.
They're warning us because we've seen
this pattern before.
Ilia Sudsker, the chief scientist of
OpenAI once said, and I think a good
analogy would be the way humans treat
animals. When the time comes to build a
highway between two cities, we are not
asking the animals for permission.
Ultman
and some of the world's top scientists
are worried history is about to repeat
itself. Only this time, where are the
animals? Sam Alman explains, "If two
different species both want the same
thing, and only one can have it, in this
case, to be the dominant species on the
planet and beyond, they are going to
have conflict."
The other godfather of AI agrees. What
happens when there's a new species on
this planet that has its own
self-interests and it can surpass us if
it wants on many domains? It can
overpower us. Then what? So how do we
avoid becoming a footnote in our own
evolutionary story? According to Sam
Baltman, there's only one path. Merge
with the machines. Not just
metaphorically, but literally. The merge
can take a lot of forms. We could plug
electrodes into our brains or we could
all just become really close friends
with a chatbot. In other words, we'd
most likely have to re-engineer
ourselves to survive. According to
Altman, this could mean brain machine
interfaces like Elon Musk's Neurolink.
They're building chips you could implant
into your brain to let you think faster.
It could mean editing hundreds of genes
in our brain cells to supercharge our
intelligence beyond anything evolution
gave us. Or it could mean something else
that doesn't even exist yet. What form
does that take? No one knows, not even
Altman. But we do know that Altman
directly claims this isn't just
inevitable, but that it's already
happening. The merge has already begun,
and it's going to get a lot weirder. We
will be the first species to design our
own descendants. This probably cannot be
stopped. But even that isn't the most
disturbing thing he said. We can either
be the biological bootloadader for
digital intelligence and then fade into
an evolutionary tree branch or we can
figure out what a successful merge looks
like. Let me make that brutally clear.
The CEO of the most powerful AI company
in the world thinks we have two options.
Merge with the intelligence he himself
is creating or go extinct. And in his
own words, we only have 1 to 5 years to
figure this out. Alman even once said
that Terminator sci-fi scenarios of AIs
going rogue keep him up at night. But
the question remains, if less than a
decade ago, Sam Alman was hellbent on
warning us about our two options when it
comes to AI, merge or die, why doesn't
he say that anymore? OpenAI thinks they
are in a global arms race. Slowing down
might mean falling behind. warning the
world could mean tanking his investors
confidence because if he really believed
what he said 10 years ago, he'd have to
act very differently. And maybe that's
the scariest part. Maybe the reason
Samman isn't sounding the alarm is
because he can't. Because the system
he's a part of is too powerful to
influence even for him. His biggest
competitor, the head of Google DeepMind,
claims that no one company can
unilaterally decide to stop an arms
race. We need an international treaty or
some kind of CERN for AGI, a pause
button we could all reach if needed
because we can't leave the future of the
human species in the hands of a few
technologists in San Francisco. This is
why I spent hundreds of hours making a
documentary on the most concrete
realistic scenario of how an AI could
take over in the next few years. This
isn't just a theory. These are the real
concerns the godfathers of AI are
sounding the alarm about. So, if you
want to understand the playbook before
it's too late, watch this video